how are you doing
good how are you
i am doing very well this is um
definitely range shirt on
yeah i do
nice i was for a little while there uh
we were in talks for me to play emily
strange when i was younger when i was
two
yeah that would have been cool yeah i
remember we had actually talked about
that once when it was possibly happening
and i was like 14 i want to say that
would have been super cool though yeah
yeah it's weird that they've never done
anything with it but no especially in
the day of in this age of streamers i
think you it would be really
interesting you know you know into it
yeah well i've always loved the
characters so yeah big time
this is definitely
an interesting project i mean i think
there's such an interesting balance to
this between this like deeply personal
human story and this like deeply
impersonal cold android story yes yeah
when this project came your way what was
your reaction the first time you read
the script um you know what i already
knew about matt and tomlin as an amazing
you know writer and and this came from
matt reeves and rafi um over uh at their
production company and i trust them so
inherently you know from the let me in
days and and uh
when they brought madison and this
project to me i
immediately read the script and finish
it within probably 90 minutes you know
it was
in and out and it was a thrill ride and
it was the way that he uh threaded the
needle between
that juxtaposition you know uh the the
the coldness and the apocalyptic
uh circumstances of it all but also the
motherhood and the love and the uh
complications of being a young mother
and in a relationship where there was
already kind of
division in a lot of ways and also to
add that on top of it it being a love
letter to matson's biological parents
you know this is a story based on uh his
own true life and and this was the end
that he found on his parents story so
that kind of personal touch to it is one
that i felt that a sci-fi film doesn't
often have
um but when you can put that into a
genre film i find that those are the
best
types of genre films is when they have
that gravity to them where you know you
can have all this frivolity in a lot of
ways and expansion but at the heart of
it you have um you know
a real story
when you read a script do you go into it
with an eye on the character you'd be
playing to see what you'd be doing or do
you try to read it more for the overall
story the first time you'd experience it
it's definitely kind of a a two-sided
thing you know it's definitely you know
uh on one hand you know what is this
character like what would it be like to
become this character what would it feel
like to step into her shoes
um
you know what you know does it scare me
as an actor you know does it does it
kind of get your get your kind of uh you
know uh fire underneath you lit to want
to have that drive to sink your teeth
into it and then on the other hand you
obviously want to watch it um you want
to you know read it as if you're
watching it and see
you know
how much of it you know lends itself to
viewership you know is it interesting is
it exciting is it enticing um does it
flow you know how much work might need
to be done to the script when you talk
to the director and all those type
things and honestly it
it was perfect as is and they were just
little things that i wanted to find with
algae in the conversation pieces that
felt right for the character and to make
her not this glowing
matriarchal
you know pregnancies amazing kind of
female
but more like this is [ __ ] hard you
know this is difficult and do we want to
do this how are we doing this you know
and can they rise above it
your primary co-star in this film is the
pregnant belly so
what was that like to wear was it
different than you expected what was
that like
yeah it was
so difficult you know it was a 21 pound
silicone belly attached to a corset so
of course it was already hard
one pound belly on the corset not very
easy um but i think you know it was
important that we wanted to find the
right closures for it that way
i didn't want to feel
agile in life you know and light and
easy i wanted to feel arduous i wanted
to feel difficult um you know i think
that was the mainstay when i talked to
uh
new mothers and and and women who have
had children was that across the board
you know
pregnancy is not easy it's very
difficult and when you're about to pop
you're pretty over at that point and
you're just ready to have a baby you
know um and so i wanted to add to that
you know and have the restricted
breathing by the corset that way in
those emotional moments like in the tent
between the two characters when we're
talking
it's hard to get your words out even you
know when you're when your heart rate
starts to get up and you're restricted
that way the constraint of it all was
was very interesting to play with
you've grown up as an actor and you've
been developing your craft for a long
time now you've already played
such iconic characters like with kick
ass and let me in and carry
even voicing a character in adam's
family i mean
how differently do you feel as an actor
at this point in your life now compared
to what you remember about your earliest
experiences because you're still so
young and yet you've had like a full
career yeah no for sure i i
agree with you on that one you know i
think it's been
really fun and exciting to be able to i
think for lack of a better word reinvent
myself in different facets of my my
timeline in my life you know from being
a child actor to being a teen actor to
doing romance for the first time on
screen and in lost for the first time on
screen and then now you know growing up
and and getting out of the high school
years and now you know being past
and then that kind of like you know
uh college sort of range where i can
play a first-time mother you know and a
young mother and and and put in new
facets of womanhood and what that looks
like and especially now in a day and age
where it's not the
uh trophy female characters that you're
uh given you know you're able to play
more multifaceted characters that are
more interesting and more realistic to
the human experience of being a woman
um
so it's been it's been exciting you know
and it's been something where
i've uh learned more and more to trust
myself and trust my gut and
i'm having more fun i think than i've
ever had
at the end of this film your character
is faced with a choice in order to give
her her child the chance of the best
life possible
what was your reaction to that ending
when you first read it and you felt that
moment
um i
was sobbing you know when i when i when
i first
read that entire moment it was it was a
sequence for me that
uh i was a little afraid of you know i
was i was i was afraid of it because i i
wanted to do it justice for matson
i wanted to
put as much care behind it as i possibly
could for him and for the story and to
honor his parents and to honor
um
honor the baby
um and
i had a rule from the very beginning
after reading it the first time once i
signed on to it i said i don't want to
walk through it
i don't want to read it out loud i don't
want to rehearse it
i want to see where we're going to be
and on the day let's just do it because
it's something that i didn't want to
hear the words
more than
once you know i wanted it to hit in the
moment on screen for the first time
and luckily we shot the film
predominantly chronologically
so this is the very end so we had gone
through the mountains we had fought the
androids we have done these things
and at this point you know as a woman
your hormones are all over the place and
i you know
almost the psychosomatic you know
mindscape where
you feel like it's your child you know i
i had this baby belly and then we did
the birthing scene where i held the baby
and then here we are faced with this
question and then
i asked matson to narrate the the letter
as i wrote it um and
it being the letter
from his mother in this way and it was
so compounded um that i don't know if
i'll have an experience like that on
another film it was very singular
but it was one of the most beautiful and
life-changing things i've ever been
through quite frankly with him beside me
um
and i i uh
i was not okay
yeah it's it's certainly it's a
beautiful moment it's a tragic moment
it's you know all of that comes with
motherhood anyway so
i think it really really encapsulates
what this story is
a hundred percent i i really think that
he did it in a way with the music and
the score and the editing as well that
it
is everything i think you need as a
viewer too to to to feel their story um
and to walk through through that story
it uh
i think was so delicately handled you
know he he really
made a movie that i haven't seen before
in a lot of ways
well thank you for talking about it
again beautiful work from you so i
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you christine i'll talk to you next time